what i want to do in this video is
really make sure that we feel
comfortable
manipulating algebraic expressions that
involve fractions so let's start with
some fairly straightforward ones so
let's say that i had let's say i had a
over b
plus
c
over d and if i actually wanted to add
these things so it is just one fraction
how would i do that
well what we could do is we could find a
common denominator well over here we
don't know what b is we don't know what
d is but we know a common denominator is
just going to be b times d that is going
to be a common multiple of b and d
so we could rewrite this
as two fractions with a common
denominator bd
so plus
bd
and actually let me color code a little
bit
so a
over b
is going to be the same thing as what
over bd
well to get to bd i multiply the
denominator by d
so let me multiply the numerator by d as
well then i haven't changed the value of
the fraction i'm just multiplying by d
over d
so this is going to be a times d
over b times d notice i could divide the
numerator and the denominator by d and
i'm going to get back to a over b
and then we can look at the second
fraction
c over d to go from d
to
b d we multiplied by b
and so if i multiply the denominator by
b if i don't want to change the value of
the fraction i have to multiply the
numerator by b as well
so let's multiply the numerator
by b as well and it's going to be bc
b
c
b c over
b d
this is c
over d so what i have here in magenta
this fraction is equivalent to this
fraction i just multiplied it by d over
d which we can assume is one if we
assume that d is not equal to zero and
then if we just multiply c over d times
one which is the same thing as b over b
if we assume b is not equal to zero then
this fraction and this fraction are
equivalent now why did i go through all
of this trouble
well now i have a common denominator so
i can add these two fractions so what's
this going to be
well common denominator is bd so let me
just so common denominator is bd
and i can just add the numerators just
like you would have done if this was if
these were numbers if these were not if
this wasn't an algebraic expression so
this is going to be
this is going to be
a
d
plus
plus
b c
all of that over
b d